foreign welcome back to CBS mornings
we've had so many mass shootings lately
it almost feels like it never stops you
know why because it doesn't and if the
sound of gunshots is just the drum beat
of life in America right now that's what
it seems like it is so painful but we
have to keep listening and actually we
have to keep talking if we want it to
stop and that's what we're trying to do
with today's story yesterday Memorial
was held to mark one year since an
especially horrific incident the racist
attack that killed 10 people at Tops
grocery store in Buffalo New York it's
hard to believe it's been a year but I
can only imagine tarika what those
people are thinking good morning to you
good morning you've covered this story
many times and you're back again this
one has a personal connection to you it
does because you know I lived there I
worked there early on in my career it's
truly a special place a very close-knit
community and almost like a second home
for me well earlier this month we sat
down with four people who were each
impacted by this tragedy Jerome Bridges
and fragrance Harris Stanfield were
working at the gross restore at the time
zanetta everhart's son Zaire was also an
employee there he was shot and
thankfully survived and garnell
Whitfield Jr lost his mother Ruth
Whitfield in the attack
if you could finish this statement
the last year has been
hard hard
very hard yeah
yeah heartbreaking
very difficult overwhelming
burdensome burdensome
it's been very heavy
the last year
the day of the massacre fragrance Harris
Stanfield was working at the Tops
grocery store along with her 20 year old
daughter I didn't die that day my
daughter didn't die that day but this
man walked past her twice
while she's sitting hiding in the store
I had no idea if she was alive or dead I
heard the gunshots coming closer I did
not think I was making it out what did
you do
I don't know I still my brain still
hasn't allowed me to see I literally
gave myself permission like it's okay
you can go you've done you've done what
you're supposed to do
it's over
I don't ever want to go through nothing
like that ever again
that was horrible
Jerome Bridges barricaded employees and
customers in a conference room to stay
safe that day when tops reopened two
months after the attack he went back to
work
foreign
go back
two people
once I found out her son was all right
that's when I decided to go back to work
his mother
God Rest her soul
I spoke to his mother
20 minutes before the guy came into the
store that's what she she always used to
lift my spirits up
she was a nice kind lady and I wanted to
shake your hand
you're welcome
a year is not
is not have you all had time to grieve
no absolutely not you know for me for
Zaire
it's like it happened yesterday
every day it's like it happened
yesterday
on this um
attention being paid to the one year
anniversary remembrance ceremonies and I
mean
I guess people the community needs to
and that's good for some people but for
me you know I don't need help
remembering my problems I can't forget
this is every day for us every day all
day every day every day
are there things that have stayed the
same that you wish changed I mean white
supremacy is alive and well well that I
mean discrimination racism all of those
things that's still pervasive Yeah in
our society and our community you know
what I'm saying so many of those things
have not changed they haven't after 5 14
the country heard it they saw
racism
out there
in their faces
but there hasn't really been any change
to it right we're not really digging
deep into domestic terrorism as a nation
and dealing with it right and so yeah
it's still the same what has changed
we've changed right 514 changed each one
of us right in different ways and we've
seen that we have to be the solution we
now know and others in the community now
know their power and they know they have
a voice and they can make change in
their neighborhood on their streets and
so that's definitely what's changed
because I know it changed me
Jerome Bridges told us he recently
started seeing a therapist annetta
Everhart who you just heard from there
announced that she's running for city
council Garnett Whitfield the former
Buffalo fire commissioner a fire
commissioner rather started Pursuit Of
Truth a non-profit organization
addressing white supremacy and hate of
course in honor of his mother and
fragrance Harris Stanfield a mother of
seven has not been back to work she
explained to me that she is still
healing from what happened you know if
you've ever lost anybody in your life
that's close to you a year is like a
blip yeah it feels like yesterday it
feels like nothing and the thing that
struck me yesterday was it was Mother's
Day exactly so all these people had to
process these feelings on Mother's day
it'll never was haunted by it yesterday
fragrance talking about I can't imagine
you having this sense that you're going
to lose your life and perhaps also your
child and you can't do anything about it
she said it was the cashier that had to
calm her daughter down and say don't say
any thing so to be that close to it and
just to imagine you know the nightmares
and the healing and the work that goes
into it I think it was important to go
back and tell their stories I'm glad you
did so unfortunate we have to keep going
back yeah because there are so many
communities like this now in this
country but that's why we have to keep
doing it very powerful conversation and
and all of them are doing something
positive to rebuild their community and
themselves powerful and necessary jarika
as always thank you very much